hello
and welcome to our second session of
this
solving large scale inverse problems in
python with pylops tutorial
my name is david vargas and i am a phd
student at utrecht university
working on seismic redating techniques
inverse problems in general and seismic
imaging today i'm going to be guiding
you through all this jupiter notebook
and i hope that you enjoy it and that
you can
learn something meaningful that you can
put
into action in your own research we will
start
by connecting the concepts that you
previously learned in the first session
and we will do that by defining our very
own
bylaws operator this is going to be a
simple one that implements
convolution and correlations next
you will learn how to use built-in
pilots operator
for image manipulation at this point i
will be showing you
how you can perform blurring sharpening
and edge detection on a very simple
image
now one of the main motivations behind
pylops
is in the solutions of inverse programs
towards the end of this tutorial we will
demonstrate the versatility
of implementing linear operators when it
comes
to the solution of a deep blurring
problem
the very last exercise will consist of
adding noise to the blur image
then solve the inverse problem and
evaluate
the performance of multiple iterative
solvers
before we start i would like to draw
your attention
to some of these useful links where you
can find more information
if you are interested in implementing
and start working with pilots
so let's get started this is a
just a very gentle introduction to the
theoretical
background and assumptions that we are
going to be using
in this tutorial now imagine you are on
holidays
and that you decide to start using your
brand new digital camera
therefore you decide to go for a walk or
perhaps
go hiking and you take some pictures of
these
really nice mountains or buildings that
you are safe that you observe
on your way by the end of the day
when you get back home you decided to
download this image
into your local laptop and display them
now suddenly you realize that some of
these image do not necessarily represent
what you observe with your eyes early in
the morning
therefore you conclude that your image
are blur
now this effect is not exclusive
of this kind of example but it also
happen
in areas like biology think for instance
on a microscope
when you observe some salts the contours
of these cells
usually appear blur also in astronomy
when you observe some of these pictures
taken by a gigantic mic
telescopes then you observe
that also the stars appear to be blur
now the mathematical model explaining
the blurring process is given by these
in the space dome index in the space
domain by this
integral equation here what we observe
is function h which is acting as a
kernel
and we usually refer to it as a point
spread function
now this kernel acts on f
the actual image that we want to
represent
and the output of this integral is going
to be our blur
image now the very same integral
in in a discrete form can be written
by this double summation
what is happening here can be understood
by following this
sketch on the left hand side we have a
point spread function
which is nothing else than a gaussian
distribution
and we want to evaluate its action on an
actual
image f now bear in mind that an image
is nothing else than a collection of
pixels
therefore we select a single one to
observe
that the output seems to be the very
same point
except for the fact that its intensity
has been distributed in space
now this operation in the frequency
domain
can be given by
means of the convolutional theorem in
this case
our function capital h is called a
transfer function
and is the spectrum of the point spread
function
a first attempt to solve the inverse
problem
consists on taking age and
divide g over h
now clearly you will agree with me that
h
most of the times have zeros on it
and also values that are really really
small therefore this operation is highly
unstable
and might cause some problems
now typically what people use to
overcome this kind of problems is
use a water level method which is
nothing else than introduce a
regularized
a regularization to stabilize
the inversion
without any further delay we just going
to dive into the actual programming part
of this tutorial
here we are importing some of the most
prominent libraries like numpy
scikit image matladlib scipy
and escui in addition to that we also
require
uh some methods from pilots
we run this cell and we land at our very
first problem
here i am proposing a one
d very simple convolution deconvolution
exercise in the forward mode
we assume to know this compact operator
h
which is nothing else than a ricket
wavelet and we can convolve this
with a vector f in the model space
the output of that operation is a
g which is in the data space
now the inverse problem is nothing else
than an attempt
to find the best model parameters f
that explain the data g
under the upper under the convolution
with operator h obviously
we can represent this problem in a
matrix vector
compact form now our operator
h becomes
a diagonally dominant matrix
and as you can see is very sparse mostly
full of zeros
which means that if you define this
with numpy most of the time you are
going to
be multiple multiplying by a bunch of
zeros
now this kind of problem is a case
for a small enough data set
however when it comes to a
large applications in real in
in real life scenarios this becomes
unfeasible
because this this operator
cannot be defined explicitly
in memory therefore
um we are also forced
to use uh some iterative solvers if we
want to so
to find the inverse of this matrix or
the
pseudo inverse in the best cases in r
now likely most of these solvers
do not require a definition or explicit
definition of this matrix a
in memory but instead they will ask
for the results of the forward and not
join operations
and that's why we are using pylops
because pilots does precisely that
it does not actually uh explicitly
define this matrix a
in memory but provide us with the output
with the actual results of adjoin
and forward operations
we start here by defining our very first
uh very simple uh pilot operator
it is an we define this by a class
that is a child of linear operator
now in the constructor of this class
we are required to pass at least three
parameters
one is the shape of the actual operator
the type of this operator and we want to
to tell pilots whether or not this
operator has an explicit inverse
the forward the forward mode is
implemented by the math
effect a method at the adjoining
mode is implemented by the r map backed
method here we wrap around
convolve and correlate which are sci pi
methods okay
let's just run this cell and in the next
cell
here we are just going to try and
reproduce the pictures that i just
showed before
we start by defining the time axis which
is
uh basically starting at a minimum
initial time then you go to a maximum
time
and we take a an arbitrary
number of samples our model vector
is nothing else than as a preposition of
three gaussian functions
and the input response or convolutional
operator
is as i said before one ringgit
wavefield
once we have this we are ready to call
our
pilots operator the one that you just
defined
and we do it we do that by passing input
the input response here
and the dimensions now this returns
our actual pylobs operator and something
that is very nice is that we can
still use a number like
syntax to represent the forward model
now the inverse is trying to
reconstruct the model by giving
to a solver in this case fifth but you
can use uh list squares or any other
solver to come play around with that but
we
basically pass the data assuming to be
no
and also the operator very important
here
we need to know how many integrations we
want let's start with 20.
and yes clearly you see
that in the forward mode we reproduce
this data
now if we assume to know the data and
the operator we want to reconstruct the
model
by solving uh the inverse program
with only 20 iterations it seems to be
doing a good job but we can just
exaggerate this
and just put it into let's say 200
and now we see that we are doing a
pretty good job
and that we have managed to convert to
our
a meaningful solution or the target
model
uh i would like to uh finish this
exercise
just by printing this by calling the
pilot's operator
just to show you that this is mimicking
a matrix that is
ten thousand by ten thousand and this is
already a
pretty large matrix for a simple toy
example
well it seems that everything is working
pretty nice for the 1d case but let's
just
increase the dimensionality of the
program and work with 2d matrices
here we learn how to use build in pilots
operator in a specific we are going to
use the pilot
signal processing called convolve 2d
and that's pretty nice because it allows
us to apply the convolutional
model that we just saw to perform some
filtering on an image
here is an example you take an input you
apply a specific kernel
uh in this case the edge detection one
and
and you get a filtered version of the
input and let's see how we can implement
this in python the first link
the first line here is just loading a
specific image but feel free to use
a different one here also make sure that
you retrieve the shape of this image
and then define your round kernel
here i am choosing a three by three
matrix full of zeros that is initialized
with a single one
right in the center this kind of a
kernel is called the identity kernel
once we have the identity we can just go
ahead
and call the convolved method by passing
the kernel and its dimensions
this in turn will return will return us
our pileups operator c and of course
before we do anything with that we just
want to check that it passes the dot
test
now if it does we are free to go
and apply it directly into our image
[Music]
and that will provide us just with a
with a blur version of the
input let's see how the output look like
first thing to notice is that yes we
pass the dot test
and second that the difference here in
the
output and input is in the order of the
machine precision
that's expected because i choose to
to use an identity kernel but i want to
draw your attention in
something here now
the shape of this image is in the order
of 500 by 500
pixels and the shape of our pilot's
operator
is in the order of 260 000
by 260 000 this is already pretty big
but like but of course this is not
explicitly defined in memory which is
the advantage of using pilots
here um we're just
proposing a first exercise
and it is basically uh has to do with
you playing around with the previous
code and implementing your own kernel so
please go ahead and spend
some time trying to do this
just to conclude this section on
filtering i will adjust
to show you a differ a different filter
that filter is called the edge detection
or sobel operator it's a very popular
one
uh in imaging and in imaging processing
and it basically takes the derivatives
the directional derivatives of
of the image along a specific
a axis x and y
if you look through this code you
realize that the dynamics is basically
the same one
except that now we have two different
kernels
and that the final image that we are
plotting
is the gradient magnitude but just go go
go ahead and run this this cell
this is what we obtain the input image
once we apply these these two kernels we
obtain the
edges of that image
and now i would like just
to go in towards the end of this
tutorial by showing you how you can
implement image blurring in pilots
the image blurring process is nothing
else
that than taking a sharp image and
convolving
with a blurring operator which is a
gaussian
filter once you convert these two
you obtain a smooth version of the image
if you look at this problem in the
frequency domain you realize that
basically
what is happening here the way this
blurring operating
is acting is just a filter
that removes the high frequency content
of the image
therefore the output is going to be a
very low
frequency content image
let's see how this
code is implemented but once again
the only difference here is how do we
define our kernel
in comparison to the previous pieces of
code
so here the kernel i'm calling again the
same com
the same convolved 2d method and the
kernel
is a gaussian kernel that is defined
here in this in this line
yeah so once i have that then i retrieve
my pilot's operator applying gaussian
filtering i just go ahead and apply it
into the intel into an input image
and that should provide me with my blurb
version of the image
the next lines is just taking
the fourier transform of this input
point spread function and also the blur
image and just to see
how it performs in the frequency domain
let's just go ahead and plot this
yes as expected you see
that this image has been blurred by this
operator
now you can play around with the
extension of this gaussian kernel
to see what is the effect on the final
image
now one of the most perhaps interesting
problems
is to assume that all we know is a blur
image and its corresponding point spread
function
and we want to reconstruct the sharper
version of this image
that will basically bring us to the last
exercise of today's tutorial where we
are going to
solve the d blurring problem in order to
do that
we will implement four different solvers
first the least squares inversion
second the regularized version of this
square
next we will be using the tv inversion
and finally we will be
implementing vista and one way
or another all of these solvers
are trying to minimize an objective
function using
an iterative algorithm for instance
if you look at the least squares uh all
what we're going to do here
is just to find a model a that minimize
the l2 norm of this objective function
you can access these squares
in by calling the normal equations
inversion
and of course you are required to give
your point spread function and your blur
image
and because this is an iterative solver
you need to pass a maximum number of
iterations
the result of this inversion is going to
be
stored in this deep blur l2
variable let's just run the cell
and jump into the next one which is a
regularized
version of the previous one where we
basically are
on top of it imposing a regularization
term
that is going to
ensure that the retrieve image is smooth
enough
to stabilize the inversion the only
difference
in the in comparison to the previous
cell is that now you call regularized
inversion
and that you need to pass you
regularized term
in this case we're just calling the
laplacian and as i said before this is
going to enforce
a smoothness when you reconstruct an
image
we run the cell and while this is
running
we quickly jump uh into the tv inversion
the way it is pose uh this inversion
problem here
is just an attempt to minimize the l1
norm
of these derivatives uh across direction
x
and white are applied on the retrieve
model
and this is subject to an l2 constraint
um you can first of you can you can
basically access this
solver by calling sparsity which is a
collection of solvers
also in pilots and select the split
breckman
option now as you can imagine you need
to pass
your point spread function and
you also need to pass to regularize
terms and in this case it's just a
pylose operator implementing the first
derivatives
and we pass the data and the number of
outer and inner operations
sorry iterations uh there are a bunch of
other parameters that you can play on
around with this and see what's
happening let's just execute the cell
and go into the final version which is
vista
here i'm just going to set that in
contrast to the previous one
we want to solve an lp norm problem
and as you can see you can access vista
just by calling sparsity
passing your gaussian operate operator
or point spread function also
the blurb image and the maximum number
of iterations
let's just run the cell and as you can
see
the result is going to be stored here in
the blur vista
this will take a few seconds but that
will give me the chance to
set what we are going to do in the final
cell
and as you can see we are just going to
plot
all the results and compare between one
another
just as a benchmark i am giving you the
original image that we want to
reconstruct but remember that we are
departing from a blur
image and a point spread function if you
look
at the list of squares inversion it
seems to be doing a pretty decent job
in the sense that it is sharper you
appear sharper than the blue
image but once you implement the
regularization term
and because this is enforcing some
degrees of smoothness
you see that there is still some
smoothness on the on the content in on
the image
now on the contrary the tv inversion
seems to be
the one that is performing best if you
look at vista
vista is also doing a good job except
for the fact that there are some ringing
effects around this
now to conclude i would like just to let
you work a little bit on this
by adding some noise into a your blur
image and try to perform
the inversions that we just did before